Mike its Ross Tucker I'm filling in for
Dan it's always good to talk with you
you know my sense Mike is that you still
probably have a couple years left in
yeah you know at least as it as a run
stuffing five technique the end and a
three-four if you wanted it do you feel
like you can still give it a go for a
year or two if you wanted to hey Russ
thank you for having me on and yeah no I
I think if you're talking about playing
on the field I think I still I still
have it definitely I think when you talk
about kind of you know do I have the
motivation to put everything in to
another year that I would owe the
organization and my teammates and the
fans I don't know if I had that in that
left and so I think it's important to
get to that point in life you know if
you're gonna do something you got to do
it on 2% I just didn't know if I had
that and then I weighed that out with
the injuries and the things that you
were talking about so you know it was a
tough decision but I think a decision
that had to be made you know so you just
made it on Monday so here we are in
early April how long have you known I
mean the season ended a while ago did
you know right after the season you
wanted to let it wait a little bit or
they just come the like this past
weekend why now yeah it's a great
question I was going back and forth on
whether I wanted to retire keep playing
and I had been tied down to the point
was probably leaning towards going back
and then my wife you know she kind of
brought me back down to reality and said
look you're dealing with all these
injuries you've had the concussions your
your level of play is not at the level
it was that you are you know you just
you know and then she was saying I don't
want to uproot the family and move out
to Kansas City again they're just a lot
of factors that I really wasn't thinking
about just because I know what the road
towards football looks like I know what
to expect and and this road in
retirement I'm not as you know I'm not
as sure you know I've been playing
football for eighteen years so I don't I
don't know if this road looks like and
so so my wife kind of Bro me
down the reality and kind of laid it out
so once we talked through all that and
she told me how she felt I said okay you
know it pushed me into her time but now
push me into their time but I it's okay
this is this is the correct decision at
this point we're talking with Mike
DeVito played nine years in the NFL he
is the latest in what seems like a bunch
of guys that in my opinion still have
the ability to play in the NFL at a
pretty high level deciding to hang up
the cleats you know last week Mike it
was your former teammate D'Brickashaw
Ferguson see Calvin Johnson Marshawn
Lynch even my former teammate Logan
Mankins I still think could have played
pretty well for a year or two do you
think that this is a trend Mike it
definitely seems that way I'm not sure
if there's a common theme towards you
know what kind of motivations are for
retiring but but you're definitely right
it's definitely something to look at
guys are retiring earlier I think that
you know the more research that comes
out on the injuries and you know what
you sign up for you know Russell has a
violent game so and I wouldn't have it
any other way but I think when the
information comes out about you know
some of the you know it's a it's a
little bit more damaging than we thought
it was you know they can you start to
think about things a little differently
especially when it comes to your brain
because if you hurt your knees you hurt
your shoulders you could always recover
for that but you know but more you hurts
you know your head you know that changes
who you are as a person and so you gotta
weigh that into account not that that's
what guys were thinking about but I'd be
curious to see what guy's motivations
were but you are you're seen guys retire
a lot earlier so it's fair to say Mike
that all the new information coming out
about CTE just based on what you're
saying it sounds like was absolutely a
pretty significant factor in your
decision it was it was one of the papers
you know I think them the most
significant fact of the Rhodes I think I
I played pretty well this year and the
one thing that I've seen with defensive
linemen is you don't you don't really
see
gradual drop off and plays like they're
playing well playing well and they get
to the point where they're you know that
[ __ ] it's done you know then they stink
in it so I don't know where on that but
I don't I was happy with my play last
year I came back from the the Achilles
injury and so I think the biggest thing
was I don't want to rob my teammates in
the organization and the fans and I
don't want to put a bad product out
there and so I think that that was
really the motivating the major
motivating factor when I really kind of
sat back and reflected on it but there
obviously secondary for that is the is
the king is the concussion stuff because
yeah you got to be really careful and
especially you know the new research
scene perfecting has a lockdown on how
tempted were you Mike to try to get that
10th year though 10 sounds cool man it's
a round number how attempted were you to
try to get that 10 next to your name oh
so much I really was and I know there's
just something about that but then again
as I kind of detached emotionally from
that a little bit and kind of looked at
it as rationally I could just thinking
am I gonna put myself through this and
go against all these other things that
we've just talked about because I want
to get you know I want to be able to say
I did 10 versus 9 you know but you're
right but there's something about 10
like a solid decade you know it just
sounds better than 9 I don't I don't
know 10 10 sounds with yet it really
dude 9 is legit especially the way you
played it yeah an unbelievable career
with the Jets and then with the Chiefs I
don't think people appreciate you know
what guys like you and any guy that
plays 9 10 plus years and laces it up
every Sunday and the trenches those are
the guys that I look at and just think I
mean what brick did with never missing a
play is just all and said I mean I try
to explain them like how crazy is that
to you that the dude never missed a play
and it's incredible the biggest that's
the whole cement Iron Man right there I
mean it's and to not miss a pie I can't
remember the number of reps I think it
was supposed to 11,000 reps
this straight that he pussied I mean it
just it's unbelievable and I was I was
fairly healthy and I did a lot to work
on my health and I still got you know
especially after years five six seven a
you know eight I missed all of eight but
there was always I always knew okay I'm
probably not you know he shoots the baby
through 16-game but but you're gonna you
know you figure okay I'm I probably
won't make it through a lot of 16 games
without getting injured and then and
then on top of that do not miss a rap
it's just it's just incredible it's
incredible I mean it's all like I know
that's definitely a Hall of Honor like
all of Fame statistic right it's right
there by itself because it's an
incredible feat and I don't know if
anybody outside the game would could
really grasp it you know hey Mike what
are guys in the locker room really
talking about this brain stuff the head
stuff is this something that's talked
about in the locker room or just
something that you guys do with your
families at home you know I think I
think it's talked about in a locked room
a little bit but I think it has I think
it has I'd be careful but I think it has
more of an effect on our families
because when my wife is lodged in 60
minutes or you know on all these
different shows that are putting out you
know the research for the CT eaves and
in the brain trauma and the stuff that
you know they're just starting to come
around and understand now I think that
that that is some at least in my case it
was you know it was a little bit more
added pressure from that from the
outside coming in because because your
family wants to you know I'm not if I
was just responsible for myself that's
one thing but being responsible you know
to take care of my wife and my kids and
be here for their I you know the
capacity where I can interact with them
you know is important and so I think you
know when they start to see it and it
starts to make the news and make the
movies like it's been I think if you
know there's a little bit more external
pressure there hey any idea what you're
going to do next that you know John
Dorsey our general manager had had a
great he I was talking to him he said
look you can't you're gonna want to jump
into something right away
he said because that's just your you
know your nature we don't you know point
football you know how it is I just like
kid you know you want to get back to
work and so he said you've got to be
able to step back for a second and find
something that you're passionate about
so don't just over jumping into
something to jump into something I
thought that was great advice so my
wife's pregnant she's due in November so
I'm gonna take time
till then that's kind of like my goal
time and spend time with it with my
family and then help her through that
process and then kind of figure out what
I'm passionate about what's next because
I really don't have any idea right now
well that is great news congratulations
and thanks for calling in today of
course thank you so much Jamie and I
appreciate the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience